if you're wondering how Keanu Reeves
became the muscle-bound movie star that
he is today watch on as we look at the
intense training that has helped get the
actor into master assassin shape Keanu
Reeves made his first foray into action
with the 1991 bank-robbing surfers Lake
Point Break this not only meant that he
had to be capable of performing stunts
and action scenes but that he also had
to learn how to surf according to
Entertainment Weekly Reeves and co-stars
Lori petti and Patrick Swayze all spent
two months taking lessons from the
world-renowned pro surfer Dennis Jarvis
as Jarvis explained Reeves had never
surfed before and all three actors were
beginners still even though Reeves was
inexperienced he gained a passion for
the sport and continued to surf as a
hobby surfing is a challenging sport
that demands a great deal of strength
especially in the shoulders chest legs
and core while Reeves didn't necessarily
get super ripped for Point Break the
effort he put into learning to surf
surely moved him into a new level of
physical fitness and capability 1994
speed was the first movie where
audiences could see Reeves really pack
on the muscle and while we don't have a
lot of information on how he got in
shape for it we do know that he went to
extra lengths to perform some of the
most demanding and dangerous stunts
himself you like the devil you know
daredevil adventure once in a while I
kind of dabble but not really not really
perhaps the most notable example of this
was the notorious bust boarding scene in
which he left from a Jaguar onto the
speeding bus Reeves wanted to tackle the
stunts himself according to director Yan
de bont
who told Entertainment Weekly he was
nervous in the beginning then he got
addicted to the adrenaline
although de bont told Reeves he couldn't
do the stunts himself Reeves practiced
secretly off set when it came time to
shoot the scene Reeves just went ahead
and jumped much to the director shock
for many people the matrix was the first
time they got to see Keanu Reeves in
full action star mode but it might
surprise you that despite all the action
scenes Reeves filmed in the matrix
intensive workouts really weren't part
of his routine his character neo was
never intended to be buff and even when
he was training for the martial arts
scenes he had to take it somewhat easy
due to a spine injury however that
doesn't mean Reeves didn't put in plenty
of sweat and effort according to kung fu
magazine Reeves and co-stars Laurence
Fishburne
and carrie-anne moss went through four
months of kung-fu and wire work training
to ensure that they had the martial arts
skills necessary to nail the complex
choreography required to shoot the
movies intricate fight scenes Keanu
Reeves has a much more moderate approach
to dieting than a lot of his fellow
Hollywood celebrities speaking to Men's
Journal Reeves described his training
diet as low sodium low fat and the night
before a big fight sequence I still eat
a steak it's a habit that he began while
filming The Matrix and that he seems to
indulge whether training for a movie or
not
Reeve said that between his films his
diet doesn't change much and that he
enjoys steak red wine a nice single malt
with a big ice cube that doesn't mean he
doesn't maintain any additional dieting
parameters reportedly Reeves tends to
avoid overindulgence and sticks to foods
like chicken steak rice vegetables and
pasta over the years Keanu Reeves has
frequently pushed his body to the limits
with Reeves in his mid-50s it's
important that he puts in plenty of
effort to avoid injury when training the
actor spends a lot of time on stretching
and warm-ups and his actual workout
routine tends to focus on resistance
bands and bodyweight exercises which are
easier on the joints than free weights
speaking to Muscle & Fitness Patrick
Murphy Reeves trainer of 25 years said
Keanu's body was put through the wringer
I had to implement the safest most
effective program possible
this meant focusing on a high volume low
impact routine with limited rest in
other words injury was avoided by
focusing on performing a high number of
repetitions rather than lifting heavy
weights it's safe to say that John wick
is Keanu Reeves most physical role and
since the assassin has to spend pretty
much all of his time fighting bad guys
Reeves has to be pretty ripped however
according to Men's Health Reeves has a
workout routine that's surprisingly
limited utilizing just six central
movements the first is a reverse lunge
front dumbbell raise which is a
full-body workout that hits the legs
shoulders and chest second is a BOSU
lunge shoulder press in addition to
working out the lower body and shoulders
this particular technique is great for
developing balance third is a reverse
step resistance band row which continues
the lower body workout while shifting
the upper-body emphasis to the back
fourth is a squat with TRX shoulder I so
hold which is a squat variation that
hits the lower body and shoulders
movement number five is a stability ball
dynamic plank which develops core
strength and balance the final move in
reves workout is a banded lateral walk
Paul off press which helps to develop
shoulder-width and leaves mere mortals
feeling sore the next day it may seem
like a fairly light routine but it
ensures that Reeves is both strong and
mobile which comes in handy for martial
arts training while training for the
John wick movies Reeves workouts have
tended to emphasize speed and endurance
over strength if you watch his fight
scenes carefully he's rarely doing
anything that requires major muscle but
instead he performs a series of highly
intricate rapid movements over a long
period of time to develop this
capability Reeves moves through his
workout in a fast paced circuit speaking
with men's health trainer Patrick Murphy
explained that Reeves cycles through his
workout routine about five or six times
within an hour and a half according to
Murphy he wasn't lifting crazy heavy
weights it was getting his body moving
getting his muscular endurance and
stability it was just a mindset he would
leave the gym exhausted but feeling
great as anyone who has seen the
resulting fight scenes knows these
efforts have paid off once the action
starts Reeves doesn't seem to stop
moving until it's all over
while Reeves performed some fight scenes
in Point Break and speed his first
substantial martial arts training came
while preparing for the Matrix according
to renowned martial arts trainer Yin
whooping we had to start from scratch
training him from the basics but he was
very hard-working and put in a great
deal of effort Reeves martial arts
knowledge kicked up a notch for the
first two John wick movies for which he
trained extensively in judo and achieved
expert level skill this went even
further for the third installment for
which Reeves learned Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
according to director chads2 hell ski
their approach was we're gonna sit in a
gym for six months and just get as good
as a Sun guy not their moves literally
be trained as eight martial
before that training began several
months before shooting and it spans
seven days a week for four or five hours
a day in an Instagram post from December
16th 2019 Terran tactical Road Keanu's
starting is training for John wick four
and matrix for parent tactical is a
training company that helps actors like
Reeves learn how to realistically use
firearms Reeves has trained with Terran
tactical before working his way through
elaborate courses and shooting ar-15s
semi-automatic pistols and semiautomatic
shotguns briefs has become an incredibly
proficient shot taking out all manner of
targets and with the additional training
furs upcoming movies it looks like we're
in for a whole lot more of the gun food
we've come to expect from the actor
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite action stars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]